Alright everyone
Welcome to Infinity Learn It by Shree
Chaitanya, you are very welcome children.
Beautiful Platform Pay With Andar Very
Beautiful class which is your NCERT line
but there is class
Want to excel at 23 or 20-24
To secure one of our government seats
If you want NCERT is your Bible now
How do we remember NCERT lines?
Keep it because every year your NCERT
Questions are made on the lines only and are affected.
Ahead of it's line C is your asked caste
So remember that line from NCERT
One way is to learn it actively.
How can they buy this format in which
I questioned NCERT lines
You have been converted to the format
The question about saree saree is that
He will get to see the NCERT line
The child is missing a word or two from the line
And you have to find out those missing 12 words.
So that you can understand that you need NCERT
how well you have understood how much
You have received the entire NCERT.
First think first children session immediately
Like this and share it with your friends
Call all your friends and become strong!
Let this fight be a good battle.
Who knows how much NCRT can be understood well?
Whose chapter has this chapter come in? Exactly Tips
I have already told you in this series.
Already finished living world
I have done biological classification.
You must go and watch that lecture once.
Try reading NCRT in this manner and then
Tell me if you want more number of questions.
Are you able to solve or not?
In this way you can be actively involved in the trust.
Will get involved in NCERT reading and you
Solve more number of questions
Good morning everyone good morning
Good morning, all the brothers who came quickly.
baby good morning yes
Yes Anvi Hello Hello Study Warrior Hello
Kanchan Hello Amandeep Hello Habib They are Sania
They Have Yes They Have Shania Mirza Said Me Some
Thomas Up and Little Heart Everyone Send Me Some
Thomas Up and Little Heart and Kids Today
Which chapter is it your cytology
Cytology We have started Cytology this
An Basic of Your
You will understand genetics genetics only when
You understand cytology well
Because you know genetics very well.
Important topics for NEET exam
Highest salary from prospectus
Topic is your genetics then cytology
If you have good command then genetics too
Ours will become very good and cytology
SELF IT SELF QUITE A GOOD AMOUNT OF
Questions come, you have only two chapters.
cell d unit of life what we will do today
Self cycle which we will do on Monday
Chapter is very important cell cycle
This is a short chapter, give it a little color
If the chapter is done then Preeti Watch will be with me.
I have 50 questions for today's class.
You will solve 50 questions today
D Class on Are You Who Exide in Class
Send a thumbs up if you're that excited.
Class Yes Main Yes Main To Ek Meri Simple Se
The request is that whenever you apply this fashion
You are sitting even if you are live with me right now
Or later you will apply your NCRT
Band all your notes to one side
You just keep one paper, one pen.
As soon as you have questions like
A word or two is displayed
If the word file in d is blank then you
Given the options, give it a go.
Trying to find out the missing word
Do it without options if not
If you can find out then you can do the options.
Look and mark the answer if you want.
Without looking at the option, catch the word
Where are you from, it means you are in NCRT.
You should become a pro at NCERT very well.
It is flowing in every vein of yours and you have understood
Yes, every line of NCRT and if you
You can understand its meaning even after seeing the tax option.
This is that you have a revision retirement
butt or just course NCERT you understand
So it must have come, ok let's go super now
Let's start today with our super.
Amazing steamy classy witch is on d
cell d unit of life first first line
Off NCERT Everywhere on Your Screen
We answer the question in time bound condition.
Will They Are Having 30 Seconds Every
Look at the questions, test your memory
Based exam is right 200 day after tomorrow we will get 200
To be completed in minutes
Question me, spare a minute.
It comes in all the questions of bio.
I will quiz the time so that your bio
time for physics their chemistry
More Back Pay Joe Right So This Time Starts
Children's answers before no time starts
This is what happened, this is what is happening, this is what is happening, soap
You like this session and share it.
Never forget this in trust
Best way to study NCERT anytime
You won't get much better now
use then believe later
Yes Good Good Everyone I'm Time Aap Karan Hota
It happened and another 26 seconds have passed.
What is the line of NCRT file in D?
Blank formulated D cell theory like this
Who is the scientist who sold the cell?
who formulated the theory of cell
Created the theory, now look at the cell theory
Your botanist and zoologists who make it
The two scientists were Skeleton and Shivam Wright.
It is written here that both this and this calendar
Scientists involved were still there
Correct Answer Bill Be Your Option Number The Witch
Is b and c both are correct is d stare
Yes let's go to the next line off
There will be no momentum break on NCERT
You will write mine on your paper.
Together Alright Next One Next
NCERT Line Everywhere on Your Screen and
Your Time Starters Right No Next Line
Off NCERT On Your Screen Well done instantly
From File in D Blank First Explained
Date Sale Divides and New Sales and R
Form From D Pari Exam Sell Something Way
call n
Something Because
Awesome superb superb everyone superb
It's like my time is running out, isn't it?
Number of pass answers increasing, very nice
Everyone Question What does File in D say?
Blank First Explain Date Cell Divide
And New Sales Are Form From De Pari
Exam cell is very important in cell theory.
Which important point was added?
Scientist Says It Was Your Red Joe Workers
They said omnicellular witch men who
New sale is debt bill arises from D free
Existing Sale which Sale Already Present
This is the date when your new cell arises.
Vaj Explain Me Yore
Dolphin right so let's go to the next line off
NCERT Pay Without Breaking the Momentum
Let's see my NCERT Pro children.
Which is Yes Next Line of NCRT
Everyone on your screen and your time
starters right no
Next Sign of NCERT Come On Everywhere
Self-Det Have Membrane Bound Nuclei
Also called cells that have a membrane inside them.
bound nucleus is present
Nucleus which is having double membrane
what do you call a bounded cell
Very nice everyone very nice you call date
I'm waiting for time to end
Maximum children answered correctly
I can't read comments so fast
Here is Abhishek Forest
Vikas Kumar Yadav Very nice Sania
Well done Kanchan very good so it should be yours
Curry Your Truck Sale View Unicellular Sale
What does it mean that the cell inside which
a cell that has only one cell and no
Division of Labor is not an organization which
Perform all functions from a single cell
Are Beat Your Circulation Weight Excretion
Wet Reproduction No Function Hedge Bin
Performed by date single sale ok yes so
Those unicellular become yours give com
What does Pro Kariarting Pro mean?
primitive primitive karyotic means
Nucleus is a cell in which primitive
Type of nucleus is found in
Prokaryotic cells say no what to do
I mean by primitive type of nucleus
a nucleus in which your nuclear
The membrane is absent such a nucleus
in which no double membrane is present
Your present in the form is Debt Bill B
Your nucleotide is prokaryotic
cells your primitive type of nucleus
where they are eukaryotic
Cells that are your advanced type of nucleus
This is your advanced type.
off nucleus joe right
Mean by Advanced Nucleus and Nucleus
Which is having present of double membrane
Bound double membrane is bound inside it
You call it advanced type of nucleus.
If yes then the correct answer is this option number C which is
D eukaryotic move next line off
Everyone Next Line Off on NCERT
Continuation of likes and shares on NCERT session
All children will maintain likes and shares
Keep it up yes let's move on to the next one
Your Screen and Your Time Starters Right
No next line of NCERT find out
d missing words and show verma show prabhas
How are you? Very good morning son.
You most welcome tu de class
yes yes next one next line off
NCERT On Your Screen D Weather D Is
Arena of Cellular Activity in D
BOTH PLANT AND D ANIMAL CELL PLANT AND
Dewar is an area in both animal cells
Where all your seller activity is
Perform what do you call date is
d director
Nucleoplasm is it's and it's
It's Side of Flowers NCERT Line
Yes yes very good superb everywhere it
NCERT writes this as your cytoplasm.
hai d site
D Fighter Plans in D Area Off
Cellular Activities in Both Plants and
D Animal Cell Correct Answer Bill B Your Option
Number B witch it sito plus ok and well
We will fix your problem now, don't worry.
Here we go to the next line of NCERT.
Pay Next Line of NCERT on Your
Screen Every Times Start No Do
Break D Momentum questions quickly
will solve
Yes yes immediately everyone fool in d blank r
Non Membrane Bound Ordinarily Found in D
Whatever cells your prokaryotic cell wants now
Whether it is a eukaryotic cell, both have
There is a type of origin which is present
It will definitely happen that this fear has taken over the brain.
Organelli What Do You Call Date What Do
u call date lot
Big super time is up to date it your
Ribosomes are something that ribosomes are
Unique Per Both Type of Sales Bus Difference
This means that the prokaryotes that contain
Your 70s will go to type of ribosome spy
And in your eukaryotes, you have a
TS type of ribosome goes on date
The only difference is the rest of the ribosomes are D.
One that your prokaryotes eukaryotes both
Okay yes, well done.
Let's move on to the next question.
Line of NCERT on your screen
Shiva Kumar
Decide on the basis of your centrifuge
It's okay anytime whatever unit you have.
Don't kick him out by joining, you have to sit down, right?
don't use forceful mind
You don't have to join this date
This is basically your sedimentation coefficient.
One Lord is all notes, one question is that
Where is the centrifuge happening?
You have named it on the basis of
Don't add date ok yes next fair off
NCERT On Your Screen Your Time
Starters Right Know Everyone and Getting D
Correct answers in this one are very good
Apart from D ribosome animal cell bill
Contains Other Non Membrane Bound
Organelli What Do You Call Date Witch
Helps in Sale Division Also in Animal
specific tu animal wonderful time
Smoking like and see i can see n
Lot of correct and correct answer session
Why are you not liking me so much?
It won't work, like it, share it immediately
Your friends are still sitting there
Call them to class who are spreading laziness.
Inside
Challenge them these facts are better than this
In this way if you read NCERT then we will get
Challenge me and call all your friends.
All this is very good to friends
It is absent in plants.
Animals Debt Bill Be Your Center Of At Unique
Centrios has also taken your membrane and this
Plant cells go to your animal
You don't see centrios in
If yes then the correct answer is bill b your option number given
witch is central let's go next line off
NCERT Pay Next Line of NCERT and
They have an one word date is missing him
We will find out quickly and it's your time.
starters right no
Your Time Starters Right Now
Bacteria have genomic DNA
Small circular di i.e. outside de genomic
dna what do you call date many such
bacteria which have dimeric DNA
Apart from that, there is an extra chromosome
DNA is also found, what do you call it?
All these force balls are very nice
In detail in the chapter on technology
You are very nice in her big book.
Every time it's up it's your plan
Plus minus that extra chromosome
Given extra chromosome means to see you
gets to
Date Bill Be Your Classmates Date Is Yours
Classmates, let's go to the next one.
Let's move on to the next line off.
NCERT On Your Screen Everywhere and Yours
Time Starters Right No Way They Have One Missing
Words in NCERT You Have to Find Out
date missing word d file in d blank
DETERMINES D SHOP OF D SALE AND PROVIDE
A strong structure supports you prevent
D bacteria from boosting and
Is there a structure collapsing outside?
What protection is it providing?
Do you call date structure yes of course very
great method shiva
Habib Arhaan Sumit Komal Marshall Gamer Sanjay
Super Bravo Everyone Date It's Your Time
Up date is your cell wall if i talk
of cell wall
Which year's shop does this find out?
And also provides a strong structural support
Isn't it present only in bacteria?
This present in your plant sale also
It is present in too your fun also but
Its composition would be different within all three.
If I talk about bacteria then they
Have peptide dongle icon layer if i
If I talk about plants, they mostly have
D. Cellulose If we talk about fungi then they
Have In And Polysaccharides Right So
Composition is different but all three
Organism you can see cell wall in it.
You get it alright, well done
Let's go to the next line of NCERT Pen.
Next sign off NCERT on your screen
They Are The One Missing Word D Plasma
Membrane is file in de blank in nature and
Interacts with the outside world
What does NCERT tell you about D plasma?
What is the nature and interactions of the membrane?
With the outside world this is imperishable
It's Frilly Permeable It's Semipermeable
And this is non of d above option is
correct time start no
Are you enjoying the session or not?
to children
Radhika Vikas Gulab Singh Anuj Ranjeet
Sania are you enjoying?
Do you want to understand how we can understand NCERT?
You can study while being active like this
After studying, solve the questions
Try to get more numbers off
You will be able to solve the question rather than donating it.
You were learning money till now
If you keep reading little by little
Will not be established in the brain
Information will not be available to you only then
There will be information when you answer the questions.
Do you activate it in the format?
learning takes place
plasma membrane
semipermeable
Semipermeable in nature to all molecules
Only a few molecules are known to not cross.
If crossed then it is semi permeable
In Nature and IT Interacts with D
Outside world they interact outside
Whichever yes is moving out in the next
Whichever molecule it is will pass on
So date bill be through your plasma
Membrane
Yes, you kids are having fun in fashion.
There was no comment box late
Sa give me feedback are you in session
You are having fun solving questions.
This type is going well with this type also
We can read NCERT. Can you read this?
Are you trying to understand yes and no in this chat?
Box everyone yes me so why not session
Like it and share it and all the others
Why should friends be invited immediately?
Let us share it by liking it and the rest
We have friends who are still in this
We face constant juggling as to how we
Remember NCERT, same 21 children.
If you are studying NCERT
How should I study NCERT so that
everything gets established in my brain
In the form of questions in plus
I can also replicate because it is important
It is important that I questions
I can further apply it in the format of
yes
Yes Nisha Ashan Region Type of Question
I do it separately son video guys
Special video inside the area
is cast in which exclusively and type
of questions for your practice
To prepare for your need.
Whatever is the retirement of H and
Everything Will Be Able To See On This
In the particular platform biome you will
You won't be able to follow this story either.
Our promise is yes yes those new children
You are liking the session and subscribing.
Also subscribe to the channel so that you have all the information.
Notifications keep coming, such countless sessions, you
The kids keep going today at 2:00
Let's have another session for you children at 12:00
I am coming to this very important session.
Joe of you also in the 2:00 pm session
You guys go ahead yes let's go next
Line Off NCRT Pay Next Line Off
NCERT Everywhere
Starters are in line with NCERT today IT
A missing word from this NCRT line
You have to find out children this way
From NCERT you can remember it on tips.
will go and not only will you remember
convert into question format
You will be able to understand it and you will be able to convert it.
Try it once, it's so good
Membranous extensions in D cytoplast
And what do you call that date also contains
pigments what would you call him do you call
date chromatophore video call date gas
Vesicles Photo Receptor or Mizo Songs
NCRT says these are your chromato
The Force These Are Yours
Chromato Force Right So Correct Answer Bill B
Option number A which is written on Chromo
Let's go to the next line of NCERT.
Next Line of NCERT Everyone on Yours
Screens and Your Time Starters Right Now
NCERT has written that bacteria
Platinum is composed of bacteria which
What are the parts of a flagella?
Present are it just d
The filament is its basal body or
All three options are perfectly correct for you.
The option is bacteria flagellum come on everywhere.
bacterium flagellum time is running out
Very nice sir Aarti you on the last question
Yes, please refresh immediately, refresh
quickly
Now you are able to become a Fletcher of Bacteria
Filament of course basal body and your book
All three things are part of your flagellum.
If yes then the correct answer is Bill B and option number given.
Joe of D About Statements Are Correct Joe
Off D Bus Statements Are Perfectly Correct
Let's go to the next line of NCERT.
Next Line of NCERT Every One on Yours
Screen Next Line of NCERT Find
Out date missing words from line off
NCERT AND YOUR TIME STARTERS RIGHT NOW
Good morning radhe good morning
site of ribosome rd site of die
Synthesis Protein Synthesis DNA
replication
what happens in ribosome
great answer
Look, understand my point, if in NEET exam
If you want to excel then in NEET exam
accuracy to perform better
Along with this, you also get retirement of speed.
Memory based exam will be given is recent
If I talk about years then it is statement based.
More questions have started coming in
At first we were scared and typed off
Just because of the question but now we feel scared
Even with statement based questions
There are some statement based questions
It is not difficult but it is time consuming.
That's why you have to practice like this
So that you can solve the questions in less time.
Give such questions which are statement based
There is a question, it will take you one minute.
Very easy because you can
Will read these correct or find out the correct
If you do then debt bill take your one minute
You should divide your time in the entire paper like this.
So that you can understand this type of question.
Give me more time, you can answer the rest of the questions quickly.
That will happen only when your concept
The clarity of which is absolutely profound is number one.
Will happen when you practice questions
You have done a very good job, this is the number.
We have to focus on both things
Understand the concept in detail
We are with him as much as we can
We have to practice questions, that's why we
We can become final only after going to the final exam.
Will be able to perform very well in the exam
Ok
Yes yes, well done, ribosome RD site.
Off protein synthesis continues on ribosome
Yours
Chain attack is they have d big units and
They have d small sub units which are in front
spilled tranaga anticode plus his
Regarding amino acids in correspondence
And finally your protein synthesis will be possible.
So give RD site of protein synthesis correct
Answer: Bill B and option number B go
Next Line of NCERT Pe Ye Line of
NCERT children you are molecular people
There are also chapters to be read and it is very
Important line of NCERT is often used in this
I have asked you for Pay P A K Times
Your request has been made urgently for PK on this line.
We will solve this with Your Time Starters
Right no several ribosomes attack you a
Single mRNA and form no single chain
The structure became yours, many ribosomes.
Attached to that is what do you call date you
We will call him 'Poly Rai' sums after thinking carefully.
Answer the question now he will be asked by the police
You will call it form, you will call it polished stone.
Or you can call it both A and B and also B.D.
correct answer
Very nice everyone
Time is up so you can give him the police form also.
It is said that it is also called poly ribosome.
These two are your synonyms.
Pooja I am from Orissa and I bill thank you
You very match Pooja sending letters of love and
Blessings to you, brother, this love of yours
is the one who always encourages me so much
I want to share such content with you children.
Keep creating more for you!
Keep giving thanks to good lecturers
You so match son yes yes yes if your
Enough
The string of all running is from late and here
Your ribosomes have just been attacked.
If you like this then what would you call this?
either polyform or polyribosome
If you can do anything then the correct answer is Bill B.
Your option number given is very A and B option.
Correct right let's go superb go next
Next Line of N on Line of NCERT
C r you have to find out d missing
word that is missing a word here
Find it out for you from NCERT lines.
Have to do it now come on everyone reserve
Materials in Prokaryotic Cells
Stored in D cytoplast in D form
In what form is the result material?
is stored
Inclusion bodies in the form of microbodies
In the form of granules or
Which form is in the form of oil droplets?
is stored in
ok let me tell you again
Kids, I'll see you back at 2:00.
Very interesting session with
You also have doubts about where your children are.
Nah, all those doubts will be your soul
Subscribing to the channel on this platform
Don't forget that it is the bell icon.
Hit it so you have all the notifications
If you like and share fashion then you will keep coming.
Shraddha is there, please subscribe also.
Yes Very Nice Everywhere Result Food
Materials in Prokaryotic Cells
Stored in D cytoplast in D form
What does NCERT write about inclusion body?
Debt Bills to be Stored in D Form of
Inclusion bodies The correct answer is option number B.
Let's go to the next line of NCRT now!
Next Line NCERT on Your Screen
Time Starters Right No Next Line
Flat and Animal Cells Are Different Further D
Farmer plant and animal cell quite different
Is
What is different about plants and animals?
Does it have a cell wall or is it plastered?
Does it have a large central vacuole?
It has all three things that differentiate it.
Plant cells are derived from animal cells.
Very nice Anuj very nice marshal very
Nice Nisha Farish Naman RS Gupta Sumit
rose awesome super kids superb so
The correct answer is that all three things are present.
See the cell wall is present in the plant.
which is made up of your cellulose
ok plaster present is yours
Chloroplast is present in it
Nature means us in comparison to animals.
Plants chosen for comparison
Nature has made plants very divine.
blessed with powers
Powers Divine Power is your chlorophyll
Now think about the molecules near the plants.
Chlorophyll molecule is present sunlight
Candied food will bear fruit easily but
Think of us, we have such a super
Don't have power, think we also have chlorophyll
If there were molecules, we would go to the sunlight.
Your food gets cooked in the sunshine, doesn't it?
When there was a need to read,
Whatever social life was needed
We also end up with static, right?
You are comfortably enjoying the sunlight
Isn't it, but this doesn't happen to the plant itself.
Nature has tightened its grip on us
Chlorophyll molecule present near
And only plants are autotrophic.
Mains he is able to size his food
For we don't field us, someone else
Have to depend on money or plants
Even on animals which are non-vegetarian
Some people depend on annual salary
Do you eat food? Yes, yes, come on, yes.
So there should be respect for plants
Very good so correct answer Bill B Plant
I have a sale wall in off course ler central
Cuckoo is and they do have presence of
Plaster and all three things are also your plants.
I am a P caste and not an animal.
Very good on Next Line of NCERT
Line of NCRT will give you the exact amount
Have to tell what NCERT has written and your
time starters right no
d time
Yes yes in human beings D membrane
Electrocytes were approximately so much
Protein and so much lipid a child is asking
Do Plants Sleep?
Look, let me tell you one thing.
I understand why you are asking the question back.
At night when you are near plants
If you go to your mother's grandmother's house
It gives you teeth near the plants
Don't let those who are singing slip also
Will be disturbed but it does not happen
Why is mom talking behind him?
What do you actually understand by the scientific method?
What happens in the daytime is the plant
Intake of CO2 in the process of respiration
Let's get the auto out and we just
do we need auto and co2 we a jai
If we out then the plant has destroyed all our
How did he fulfill the requirements?
We are taking out autos, we are receiving autos
If yes then it is better to go near the plants
goes because our system is good
Circulation will be possible because external
Abundance of oxygen in the environment is
Present because of the presence of plant
Ok let's do the process at night time
This just reverses at night time
There is a plant, it is also receiving o2 and co2.
If we are doing X then if we are near the plant
If you go to our neighborhood,
We also have more co2 in the environment
Need more oxygen so that circulation increases
But there is more co2 in the environment
That's why you are understanding what I am saying, Mom and Dadi.
Nani tells you that at night time
Don't go near those plants now.
There is power behind it to attack anything.
That friend is going to plant soni at night
Neither do these vampires come at night
Any exercise on plants
Statement Dal Karke But Actually Scientific
She was trying to understand the method itself.
did you understand my point
So this line of NCERT in Human Being
D MEMBRANE OF D AIRVOCITE HJ APPROX
52% of D Protein and 40% of D Liquid
NCERT writes that 52% of your protein
and 40% of your lipids become
ok let's have a superb session
Like and subscribe the channel now
that right now
ok ok let's go next
Next Line of NCERT on Questions
Everyone
Starters Right No Next Line
Proteins Are Partially and Totally Bird in D
What proteins are in plasma membrane?
which is buried inside the plasma membrane
Is it partially or completely inside it?
Are burdened and are integral proteins.
de side chain protein
or which proteins are from glycoproteins
which lies in the middle of the plasma membrane
Many are present in the form
good time running out correct answer
Meeting Ranjan Gupta
Mirza Nisha Anuj Aarti method very nice
Super Everyone Correct Answer Bill Be Your Integral
proteins that are your integral proteins
which are in the middle of the plasma membrane
Present is obviously present outside.
If he is in the middle then the President will be on the side.
The chain is already on your side.
IT SHOULD BE YOUR INTEGRAL PROTEIN
The answer is your option number A which is integral.
Protein Alright let's move on to the next page
Abhishek will not happen son, ok next
Questions on your screen and your time
starters right no
NCERT's line is children you have you
Find out the missing words which are missing from here
The structure of the cell membrane has changed.
Proposed by the cell membrane that floods
Who explained the mosaic model?
And which was also widely accepted
Who explained it? Yes Scientist
I have asked you the name of date singer and
Nicholson Way Date Grippit Baz Date Marshall
nirenberg
Very nice every time this is up by the way
Not to be confused with Your Singer and Nicolasation.
Is
Sanger struggled to do sequencing
Human Genome Project had explained the method
The sequencing that takes place was explained in
us through the struggle method this is yours
Singer and Nicolas I Just Wanted You Check
whether you are confused by this or not
If yes, then the correct answer is Bill B and Option Number.
Be Witch Is Your Singer and Nicolas Wright
Let's go to the next line of NCERT.
Every one on your screen and d time
starters right no
Yes, I have signed off NCERT next.
Molecules can move quickly and cross d
Membrane without other retirement off
Energy and this is called
are molecules that pass through membranes
Can do without other expenditure
D Energy does not cost any ATP
Still those molecules are able to pass what
Do you call it osmosis? We will call it osmosis.
called active transport
Active transport says yes come on
children
Very nice very nice super quick
Answer Give me just one second
Yes yes yes brother whether you are active
If transport is active transport then
D Moment of D Molecule Bill B N
Long D concentration gradient will be or
IT bill will be against gradient
Your against the gradient
your
There will be higher concentration in A transport
Yes will go towards lower concentration
So the correct answer is bill b your option number c witch
The cost of this passive transport ATP here
Pay does not happen, no ATP is required
D Moment Bill B Along D Credit And
Here your ATP is required D
Moment bill be against de great and so right
The answer is bill be your passive transport
our clear and me clear
Jo am i clear yes i am yes i am super
next one
Next One Moment of Water by Diffusion
This is called forward diffusion if water
There is a movement of what do you call date
This is also your NCERT line
Moment of water by diffusion is called
Further it is called osmosis. You do this and you do that.
Active transport says kids charge
Movement or Facilitator Diffusion
They say great time this up next
Line of NCERT Everywhere Correct Answer
This moment of water by diffusion is called
forward osmosis awesome superb superb
Superb brother, come here, I have a small message.
I want to give the children who are still talking
I am involved, you understand what I mean when
The exam will be done after that and neither will this
The person chatting will be with you, right?
Then the result will be deprived of both the things.
If you go, focus on one thing at a time.
For now, focus on preparing for the exam.
Lo, many people lined up to sit.
Will give if you perform well
If you become a doctor after clearing the NEET exam
You won't have to speak like that today
Line up to lick you
People will be busy first, okay?
workout yourself like this
Make suction so that no one asks you whether you are like this
You are forcefully asking everyone to say yes, chat.
do it let's chat
Yes yes let's go superb I'm next line off
Let's go to NCERT
Next Line of NCERT NCERT
You have to pay attention to what is written
Pay attention to what NCERT has written.
Algae have cell walls made up of algae
What is the cell wall made of?
Calcium carbonate from cellulose
From or and of de most statement r
Character Time Starters Right No Yes Yes
Ranjan Gupta Very nice Nisha Very nice
Nirjula Kumari Vishwas Aarti
perfect perfect
This line is mentioned in NCERT.
The line is your mention in this chapter in which
It is written that people have cell wall made up of
Sahanji, Anuj is exactly given in NCRT.
n-cellulose galaxicalcium carbonate which
D Above Statement R D Correct Wants
ok ok i was wrong yes marshal
That's why it went wrong because we remember it.
If yes, if this N plant is isolated then in that
There will be cellulose but if we NCERT
We will know only if we remember each and every line of
Shall be there is wrong tense with salilos also.
I will also tell you about calcium carbonate.
In 2020 a question came about
And about translocation of water minerals
Now there is no such interesting question in that.
But what an option was transport of water?
Mineral was an option, your transporter
hormones also so if you look at it
If you go to the chapter, you will get the last one.
It is mentioned in the paragraph that
Exactly what nutrients
can transport that's why I say
I hope you don't miss a single line of NCERT.
Yes, you can't do this in our place
The thing is that through jealousy your
There will be transport of water minerals
But we do not know that and
What are the things involved?
For that inside the transport we
You will have to read each line of NCERT
Whatever I say, you guys can understand it in a simple way.
The author of NCERT has this task.
How many motorcycle books have you been given?
Now write consciously on a small page.
Understand him, him, the dilemma of a human being, you understand him.
I put it on his shoes and thought that he
It was said that where each chapter
The whole book becomes shakti hai chapters with cells
You will get complete books on
You can get complete books on molecular basis
You will get complete books on genetics
Will summarize it for you in 5-6 steps
Now I have to write and put him in the shoes of a human being.
Look at him he thought how can I
Important words fit the story in a similar way
If it is done, then you understand that he did this task.
That's why you have to read every single word.
Is necessary even if it is an extra in the summary
The examiner has written the line whether he wants it or not.
Add an extra word below the diagram
Mentioned may be introduction
why not something extra in that part
You have written it but you have to remember every single word.
Must read NCERT to NCERT
Your question can also be formed from the story.
And in the exam you will be told that NCERT
The paper was NCERT paper, that's why you should read it.
It is your duty to follow the instructions of NCERT.
Don't miss any lines ok
Yes, let's go to the next line.
Off NCERT Pe Next On Air Screen
and time
i have my 11th bad martial gamer 11th
if it is bad then make it good
Do it, it's a very simple solution.
If your backlog has been cleared then
Do it, don't send a separate angel.
The magic band will go spinning and your mind
Eleventh will insert you into the study itself
I will have to promise myself that I
Include 11th in your time table
I will do it from today itself in 11th class
After reading, I will also follow you here.
Morning is conducting daily classes
11:00 a.m. Your class is sharp every day.
We are following the topics of 11th and it is ok.
Let's take questions in time.
Layer Melee Consisting of Witch Holds and
Glucose D Different Neighboring Cells Together
So your calcium is in the middle level.
goes
Different Neighboring Sells Together Different
By gluing neighboring cells together
If you want to keep then the correct answer
Let's go to the next line of NCERT.
The witch is on your screen and two members
System, pick any year on this topic.
The question is not yours, PA Kabs Aap
Pick up this year's P, why should you pick it up brother?
Questions have been raised about Indo Membrane System
Above very important topic d indo
MEMBRANE SYSTEM BILL INCLUDE AND MAJORITY
Off day the question is what?
What functions are involved in organelles?
Is performing this 2023
Question: Children had come to Indo Mebarane.
What ordinances are involved in the system?
Is it number one? What are its functions?
Numbers are there, you just remember two things and
You are good, give me some questions
Will go from here yes yes time is up d indo
Membrane systems include endoplasmic
reticulum golgi complex
Analytical, these four are organized for you.
End membranes are part of the membrane system.
Ok
Well done let's go next sign off
NCERT Pay Next Line of NCERT
Everyone on your screen and time starters
Right No D Endoplasmic Reticulum
bearing ribosomes on their surface called
You have two types of SAR: endoplasmic.
You have two types of reticulum, one is
Your rare witch is rough endoplasmic
reticulum and second is s ar which is
Smooth endoplasmic reticulum in both
There is a major difference because of that
Functions are also different and in AR
The presence of ribosome which max d
Appearance rough because of this Appearance rough
Now ribosomes are absent here
date is same d appearance is smooth smooth d
foot answer ribosome are present same this
Protein Synthesis on One Bill Function
Someone here will synthesize protein
Ribosome is not a part of this bill.
In Leopard Synthesis I understood this.
Bill participates in Leopard synthesis
Questions come on line of NCERT
come with sage d endoplasmic
Reticulum bearing ribosomes on D surface
We call such endoplasmic reticulum rare or
Rough endoplasmic reticulum says smooth
Your ribosomes will be absent, ok yes
Let's go to the next line of NCERT.
If you have any doubt, please child.
Ask me if any gas is in doubt now.
Am a very happy tutor who can help you with your doubts.
You can ask in the comments or during the session.
You can also send me your comments in
I reply to the comments of each class.
I will definitely give classes to you children.
After this, please leave your comments in the comments.
If you have any question, you can write to him class.
You must write how you liked it, ok, let's go
superb
Let's go to the next line of NCERT.
Next one on your screen your time
Starters Write No File in D Blank
File in D Blank Frequently
Observed in D cells actively involved
These protein synthesis and secretion proteins
Synthesis S A R Golgi Bodies R A R
Directive and Songs Protein Synthesis
Who participates in
ribosomes do i ribosomes do
I'm running out of time and the right answer
Devil Shiva Om Vaishnavi Sania
Very nice children very very nice very
great super correct answer
reticulum in which your ribosomes are present
and ribosomes today which are found in
D protein factory of d cell right to r
Har Is Frequently Observed In D Cells
Actively involved in D protein synthesis
And following the secretion line of NCERT and
Next Line of NCERT Pay on Your
Screen Next Line of NCERT Every
One on your screen de date it de is de
Synthesis of Leopards Wrapped at Major Site
Man, there were two types of R A R N S C R.
Ribosome is attached above RAR.
Max D'Appearance Raft Thoughts Same Arrear
Ribosome is absent on SCR
Max D Appearance Smooth Thoughts That's What S
ir is yes ji file in d blank is d
SYNTHESIS OF LIPID IT BILL AT MAJOR SITE
Be your it bill be your s i r i r is
Protein synthesis and SIR at the D site
Lipid Synthesis My Talk on This D Site
Got it, yes let's go next sign off
on NCERT
NCERT Everywhere on Your Screen Too
Important Interesting Line of NCRT
Is Next on Your Screen and Term Tara
right no
D Time Start No D Animal Cells Lipid
Like steroid hormones are synthesizer in
Lipid like steroids in animal cells
Hormones are where they are synthesized.
in ar
in tonoplast or nucleus only
Very good answer in nuclear learning.
Very good answer, superb, superb, everyone comes.
IT'S YOUR SIR'S SMOOTH ENDOFLASS
Reticulum Ribosome Raps
on responsible
lipid synthesis
Your Protein Synthesis on Responsive
That's right, yes, that's right, the right answer is Bill B.
Your SIR is Smooth Endoplasmic
Reticulum move to next line off
on NCERT
very important
This line is used
Important site of formation of
Glycoproteins and Glycolipids
Originally responsible for glycosylation
bill b
Where is glycosylation taking place?
Children, tell me quickly where Glide is going.
Salutation to brother very nice everyone Anuj Naman
Chaitanya Aarti Sumit Ma Patel Naman very much
This is about a great future, right answer?
Bill Be Your Golgi Apparatus To Golgi Apparatus
Glycosylation occurs in glycoproteins.
and synthesis of glycolipid Bill B in D
Golgi Apparatus So the correct answer is Bill Be Yours
Option No. Yes Last Line of Golgi Body
These are the answers bill b your option number b
Which Golgi Apparatus Go Next
Line Off NCERT Pay Next Line Off
NCERT Everywhere on Your Screen and Your
Time Starters Right No Like You So Match
Are Rich In Almost Which D Type Of
hydrolytic enzymes optical
Active Active Ate Neutral F Basic F
Alkaline pH or Acidic pH
How many interesting lines are there in NCRT?
How many interesting lines are there in NCERT I Yes?
Time is up and everyone of you're correct
It's your acidic taste so much
All hydrolytic enzymes are and that
Where are acidic substances optically active?
Pay
ok yes tell me honestly first
What is this method in a quick chat box?
NCRT is getting better understanding
Are you without steaming your brain?
Looking at the options he found a missing word
What are you doing by finding out yes and no in D?
Chat box yes and no with your thumbs up and
With you little heart are you without options
Looking at him find a missing word
Out tax and children in trust
This way you will be remembered forever
Will see if you are studying NCERT.
lines are being read by doing are being read by
You read it twice, three times, or five times.
After reading, you will understand those few lines.
You will be able to remember but if you do this once
Once you read it, you will always remember that line.
And you can also solve questions based on that line.
You will be able to ask which is more important
Because he cares about your performance in the exam.
Are you doing this and will decide our seats?
Are you becoming a doctor or not?
ederwise how much do you know what do you know
Don't worry, OMR seat is all you need.
Will she explain whether the election took place or not?
Yes, there should be a session for every chapter.
This way
This is how I have made you the living world
I have done the classification so the old sessions
You must see the upcoming lecturers
Come live, kids, watch this class live.
It is fun to do it only if you later
If you look at it in record form then that much
Reason being will not be able to create interest
Right now everyone is replying together.
I am pushing you without option
If you answer while watching, even live
You are very able to interact with your questions.
If you can ask me then come live to the class
Like the session on daily basis
All you have to do is subscribe to the channel so that
You will get all the notifications as soon as possible.
Our time is 11 o'clock, we will meet back at 2:00
Start on this channel at
yes let's go
Let's go to the next line of NCRT.
I am looking forward to seeing you very much sir, you are very excited sir.
I am excited to see the children looking absolutely superb.
Next line is in exit mode
NCERT On Your Screen Your Time
Starters Right No Find Out D Missing
Term de vacuum without options
Is bound by a single membrane vacuole
Bound by single membarane and single
What do you call the membrane? Capsule is this
IT'S CELL WALL IT'S IT'S STONE OF LAST IT
Its plasma membrane is a single
Membrane What Do You Call Date Single
Membarane Very nice very nice ma
Patel Gulab I can't see the name
So I pick whatever name I see.
I am doing it Ashwini you with me Chaitanya
Very nice Anuj Kumar Very nice
kids superb superb it is a turn off
The last single membrane present is called
If you both say last then the correct answer is Bill.
B is your option number A both plasts are ok
Let us now answer all the questions that follow.
You guys are right by writing A B C D I
Will write the answer so that I can understand
You have given the correct answer or not
If you want to prescribe Tonoplast then you should
There will be two benefits, the first benefit is that
Without seeing you option you understand that
Answer: What will be the second benefit of this?
It will happen that once you write it down
better inside your brain
Information will be stored a lot
I only talk about scientific things.
I only rely on proven facts for scientific purposes.
I am telling you as much as you want to write.
Things are stored so much in your brain
There are many things, that's why we say them again and again.
Keep making notes, make your notes, that's why I said
Okay, come Manju, what time is class?
Classes start at 11 a.m. Shortcut 11 a.m. Daily
Basis Alright Yes is the correct answer then option
Number A Witch Turns Off Last
Next Pay Next Line of NCERT
Everyone
have to type
Hey Kyari type will also work yes I mean
This is what I want to say written in the comments
I have the answer, ok you can type it.
Let's write the next question on yours.
Screen Next Line of NCERT in
Plant Cell D Can Occupy Up To 90% Of D
Volume of D cell in plant cell
What is 90% of volume of sale?
Occupies this IT starnet this
It's ribosome, it's nucleus, it's it
Vacuole 90% of D Volume of D Cell Yes
This is very good, very good, isn't it?
This is what happened, it is yours Pooja Kumari
Hey son, this is what happened on the next question.
Well done it's your vacuum everywhere plant
Your visuals can occupy you within the cell
90% Off Volume Off Sale The correct answer is this
Your option number is vacant then we
Give the correct answer by writing option A B C
I will write this thing, let's go to the next line.
Off NCERT Pay Next Line Off NCERT
Everyone on your screen no matter your time
Amba in amba de is important
How does excretion occur?
through food
Through Gesicle or through Sun of this renewal
How will ejaculation take place in Amba? What is this?
Do not write excavation ABCD on important
Sumit Know A B C The Allowed
no a b c di allowed this is what happened aman
Tiwari also this matter Sumit Shaikh Vidhi Farish
Very good now very good smell very good
Ranjan very good my button worked
Is
Chaitanya Very Good Chetan
this important
Your Contract Tile
Excretion on the vacuole is important
required to ext
Let's move on to contact vacuum next.
Line Off NCRT Pay Next Line Off
NCERT Find Out D Missing World
Every One D Inner Compartment Of
Mitochondria is called
The inner compartment of mitochondria is called
What would you say if mitochondria are double?
Membrane Bound Organelles They Have D
outer membrane they have d inner membrane
Asked you what is your inner compartment?
Crystal Sister is said to have created the Matrix or
Very nice good afternoon pooja very soon
came to class
Very good answer, very good, very good
line off ncrti is line off
NCRT inner compartment is inner membrane
Do not pay attention brother children inner
Compartment is the debt bill of mitochondria
Be your matrix, look, this is your outer.
Membrane is the mount of mitochondria.
Remembering it out or your inner membrane
is in d form of in folding which what
You call it crystal, this is your crystal, this is
The inner membrane is inside it which
The compartment is full date it's yours
matrix
Mitochondria are called matrix.
Power House of D ATP Understand my point Power
House of D ATP
Glycolysis occurs in the cytoplasm
cancer cycle
Another important reaction occurs in
That's your electron transport chain.
In your matrix of D mitochondria
It happens and with the help of Etsy you all
able to harness atp
In the glycolysis scrap cycle we
Basically Reduce Ray Coins IMS Nadhus
F di ha you are making that from which we
ATP will attract out, understand my point
Understand my point so that we can extract ATP
You will get it out. Understand it like this, Nirja.
Kumari, you should understand it in such a way that if I
I say come on I gave you ₹100
You go and buy some society for me
Bring me some society, I am giving it to you.
Ok and with that I will give you ₹100
Even if I give you a cheque, when you go to the shopkeeper's office,
What will you think if you go nearby?
Will you be able to buy the society in cash or by cheque?
Will be able to buy but do you think
Yes yes, I will do this chapter also son.
Answer me, I also gave you ₹100
I also gave you a cheque, it was debited with ₹100.
Bill Be Able To Purchase De Sum On And Date Check
cash yes bank
So in any reaction that produces your ATP
Date ATP is taking out something that you
That's what you are doing immediately.
It's something like your cash but which
Is it like your check when you check it
If you deposit in the bank then the bank gives you
Will give ₹ 100 to whom you will be able to do it in D
Similar they are an idiots hd h2 you
Bank means in electron transport chain
If you deposit then he will give you ₹80
If you can do it then you will get Stone F.
A.D. Yes, basically your ATS only.
Keep ATS only but they have you
Deposit date in bank which is called
electron transport chain ok
Now don't answer like this friend, don't answer like this
That I will do Paytm, yes, what is this?
there is talk, what is this talk?
Their Paytm has become cashless these days.
People what do you call date give x all that
Yes, I agree with this but we
The people of old times are in our time
Cash and check were only two things brother, ok
Is
Children on Next Line of NCERT
Next Line of NCERT on your screen
and time
Yes, that is absolutely correct Nisha
i please repeat this line this one
Mitochondria R D Site of D Site of
What Aerobic Respiration Cell License
formation or hydrolytic enzymes
Production de rd site of what
Very nice answer kids, very nice
Time is Up the RD Site of Aerobics
Why is respiration just aerobic?
If I talk about those aerobic respirations
D one step witch is both aerobic and
aerobic in this glycolysis and aerobic
There will be only glycolysis and fermentation.
Both cytoplasms will not settle down.
They have aerobic respiration
Which type of aerobic is your number one?
glycolysis number two website number three
electron transport chain glycol
ISIS will be in my cytoplasm
But the product which is periodic acid
debt bill [ __ ] dr tu d inner microcontroller
Membrane where your crop cycle will take place
Crepe Cycle and Glycros which is my anode
Tu hd h2 bane hain him me hardness kar hai
I will find it ok inside my matrix
Yes and type of question son I separately
I will show you in the video, right?
Refer from there, we are studying this NCERT.
Do you understand the importance of this session? It is no different.
These are not questions from NCERT only.
The line is one or two from the NCRT line.
Missed the word if you don't
If you understand its importance then you will
NCERT will not be able to avail its benefits either.
The line of sarees is one it is no question
I have not made NCERT line
Picked up one or two words missing and the same
I am asking you only this NCERT
The way to read is to read NCERT.
The Right Way By Active Learning Thoughts That
Right Answer: Bill Be Your Aerobic
Respiration goes next line off
NCERT Pay D Matrix Off
Mitochondria Bill Have What Time
start no key
debt bill has single circular dna
Molecule de have fu rana molecule de
Have 70s ribosome they have which d now option
R correct
matrix of mitochondria
What is part of the flood substance?
What a wonderful present, kids!
superb super super so mitochondria
Yes there is presence of in matrix
Single circular DNA molecule is why we
Mitochondria are semi-autonomous organic
They also say that they understand what I am saying.
Also called semi-autonomous and organelle
Half of This Protein It's on Which Mains
Depend on de nucleus butt rest
Half of It You Can Synthesize by Itself
He can synthesize by himself right ernie
Molecules will be yes course ribosome is
Also Dewar which men's it comes in D size
D protein
Can make half of your protein but rest
Half At Is Dependent On D Nucleus No
Come, all these three options are perfect for you.
Which is correct?
Your single circular DNA in the matrix
Molecule is also there and fountain is also there and good
focus on ribosomes mitochondria which
D found in d how of you care your butt
Your 70s Type Off in Mitochondria
Ribosome is believed to have been found in the 70s.
It is said that once and prokaryotes only
Sim biotic in eukaryotic by size
Started living there and established there
There's Something They Call Undo Simmonds Theory
right yes
Right Correct answer is this option number
Statement: Hey kids, let's go right.
Next Line of NCERT Pe Next
Line of NCERT on your screen and your
Time Starters Right No Find Out D
Missing word from DT NCERT
Quickly identify the word that is missing.
Mitochondria divides by file in d
Blank brother, I get 100 likes on this class.
Want 100 likes right now Sher from Fatafat
You can like the handle by doing this so good
Condoms are you getting your NCERT
I took the responsibility of paying tips
Are you in the session quickly? 100 right now
Show it by liking, well done!
very good very good superb superb
Superb Everyone D Mitochondria Divides
bye fashion break fusion join okay two
fuse when molecules join together
When they break, they become fission.
If any extra growth has occurred
Gami Gami Cup shows that it is your bed.
where do your specials go
Which is found in bryophytes?
Method of asexual reproduction
Mitochondriality Wide by Fine Toot
Yes yes children let's go to the next line
Off NCERT Pay Next Line Off NCERT
Very nice line off on your screen
NCERT: Ribosome was first observed
Inside a 3D electron microscope
particle by ribosome first
D electrons were observed inside
Microscope by a very famous scientist
What was the name of that famous scientist
Brother again you went to ABC not ABC
Write what is the correct answer? Yes.
Yes, we want that after this class I
Don't have to raise this chapter again
After class I will ask all the questions based on this.
A little less than writing ABC.
Will it not happen? What is the answer? Write to me.
Pooja Kumari Farish Very Good Sania Very
Good method Very good Chaitanya Well done son
Sheik Very Good So It's Your George Palette
Sir, he did this to the ribosome.
first observed in d electron
micro electron microscope ok
That is why it is also called reverse particle.
We overturned it in the name of scientist
Particle is also said, brother is also a scientist.
Have made a discovery, own it a little
So it is divided that is why you see maximum space
With the name of the scientist attached to it
If my second name becomes yours then let's go.
He is on the next line of NCERT
Next Line of NCERT Everyone on Yours
Screen and your time start no
Functions in N Cell and Involved in
Mechanical Support Motility Maintenance of D
Shop of De Sale which original or such
Which part are you looking at?
Motility is involved in mechanical support
Is responsible for and maintenance of d
Shop of D Self is then responsible for this
Microbodies it's it cell wall is it
plasma membrane and it
Cytoskeleton This is a great answer
Well done kids it's your sitop skeleton
So your NCERT says de sito
skeleton d cytoskeletin in n cell r
Involve in verification mechanical support
Number One Motility Number Two Maintenance of D
Shop of D cell number three all these functions
Involved in is the correct answer bill be your option
Number the witch is sitting skeleton alright let's go
Hain Next Line of NCERT Pe Next
Line Everyone on Your Screen Your Time
starters right no
Next Line on Your Screen Everywhere File
In de blank is an organically usually
Containing Two Cylindrical Structure
What is such an organelle called?
In which two cylindrical structures are present
Both are there. You have to tell me about the organelles.
The name and the cylindrical structure are also in this
It's centrosome exonemes is it's
Centrosome central is it's sister
It has Golgi and tubular structure
I can't see ABCD son
ABCD I can't see Sumit
Marshall I can't see ABC
Write the correct answer. Henna is a filter in eyes.
I have gone to watch ABCD, the band has become too much
Good Recipe Very Good Pumpkin Singh Very
Good Asnia Ranjan
Tiwari
[music]
say the right answer
on NCERT
NCERT Everywhere on Your Screen Next
Line of NCERT on your screen your
time start no d interface nucleus
HALI EXTENDED AND ELABORATE NUCLEAR
Protein Fibers What Do You Call Date
In the interface nucleus we have
EXTENDED AND ELABORATE NUCLEAR
Protein fibers are present in it
You call it histone, you call it nucleus.
It is called chromate or u
chromate is called
In the protein itself they have euchromatin and
Heterochromat Pooja Kumari Chaitanya Ashniya
Sumit Well done Sumit Very good Farish Nisha
Sania Ma Patel Arshia Mirza Marshall Aman
Tiwari Vidhi Ravi Jha Abhishek Patel Very
Awesome superb everyone it's yours
Chrometon It is your Chrometon Chrometon
If you look at
By staining you will get a heterochromat
get a euchromatin get some
There is a part which is lightly stained.
The part that is density stained is
No because it is density packed so that
Dark color is visible to you due to light.
You can see a little space in it
The prefix is ​​the one in which the space is present.
Transcription will be active which is dance
it will not be transcribed at all
ok so heterochromatin this dense paste
and transcript inactive and u
Chrome is your lightly pet and
Transcription it is active right now
Yes then the correct answer is this option number C which is
chrome change let's go next line off
NCERT and Thoughts D and Off D Session
Yes, that's right kids, please like the session.
Please share this, promise of 100 likes.
You did 100 likes so quickly.
feels like the next one will happen in a minute
go and let's meet
We will be back today before the next class.
Will meet
Yours is a very interesting class at 2 o'clock.
A question relief in your place I
How many mock test papers should I take?
Is it important to marry him or not?
What help will I get from Hai Pew?
Saree buttons will be highlighted today
Sharpest Tu PM Sab Be Live Everywhere And
Newbies should subscribe to the channel.
Make sure to hit the bell icon and
If you comment during the class, I will know about it.
Let us know how you liked the class if you
Want More Classes Like This So Do Let Me
Your every no and d in the comment box.
I will definitely see the child's comment there.
And whatever questions you have I will be at 2:00
I will do whatever depends on your question
All those questions will be discussed today.
Live everywhere between two o'clock and two o'clock
Make this session a lion also so that all your
Friends also join him, okay let's bye.
Kids Love and Blessings You Who Me Kids Out
Dear and again don't forget you like lion and
Subscribe tu channel me everyone